what is the story structure of a short
film
because short films can do anything or
say anything and they should be
unexpected and you can do act
you know your ending at the beginning
and you're beginning at the end there is
no structure so but i do think
simplicity helps a lot i don't think you
should have a hundred different
characters with a hundred different
plots going on and a b lines it's not
like screenwriting that's when people
take do a short film screenwriting i'm
always kind of like what could you be
talking about because there aren't the
same kind of rules as there are for
features it really depends on what story
you want to tell and then i just think
it's a lot about simplification
and really bringing it down to a simple
idea and one thing i love about short
films because i'm known for short films
right people always say to me oh i saw
this really great short film and then
they'll tell me the short film that they
saw so i haven't visually seen it but
i've heard someone tell me to and i'll
be like that sounds like a great short
film and i kind of feel like i've seen
it because they were able to tell me the
whole plot of what it was
so you know
your short story your short film should
work in that way that people can tell
you what it is but a lot of them are
like just visual one of my favorite
kinds of short films are dialogue free
short films where there's absolutely no
dialogue but it is all told you know
it's not like an old-fashioned running
pushing piano up the hill and having a
fall down laurel and hardy kind of thing
but just you can tell a story with
visuals
the actual old-fashioned visual
filmmaking way um and it's great
and so many and those i'll also say the
short films with no dialogue translate
very well translate uh very well for
different countries people love films
with no dialogue because it's universal
it's going to be a universal story of
something that is told through cinema
it's a very cinematic way of telling a
story but anyway so yeah nothing you
know you can do anything you want to do
and i could try to talk you out of like
don't do like traditional structure but
you can do traditional structure if
that's what your story needs and is to
be told um
endings are really important in short
films beginnings are really important to
short films and middles are very
important in short films i do think
every scene in your short film should
also you got to look at it and say
beginning and ending you know are we
lingering too long can we get out and do
that before you shoot it because you
know again
every moment counts and if you're going
to have a longer shoot if you have a
bunch of stuff in it that later you're
going to cut out in editing
the value ever seen
look at the does it start as late as it
can does it end as early as it possibly
can and then do you really need it
what is the scene actually about and
have we already done that
i hate short films where it just takes
forever to get to the story line or they
they have a big opening credit sequence
of somebody driving in a car with
beautiful scenery going on and the
credits say you know costumes buy and dp
buy and it's like no for feature films
contractually you have to do that they
have to have full screen credits for
short film there's no thing like that we
have no opening credit sequence people
don't want to sit through that we don't
want to see that start right away with
what your story is
and you know you don't everything it
should be what needs to be nothing
superfluous nothing that is just there
because it may entertains you
you know you can have a super chatty
film too
but just make sure everything that's in
there in chatty needs to be in there
so so i say probably the biggest thing
about the structure is just
make sure it starts good make sure it
ends good make sure everything in there
needs to be in there has to be in there
and as tight as possible
and that you're happy with it
it sounds like like you said earlier if
someone's walking to go somewhere have
them be already there exactly and then
for the ending
don't have it abrupt have some type of a
payoff
you know sometimes abrupt dating is fine
too but they haven't you know work in
some way okay the other thing i should
say too is another
huge pet peeve is too long of credits
because on the festival world your short
film will quite often be put in a
program of short films so the audience
watches one short film has to sit
through like two minutes of credits and
then now they're ready to see the other
short film and running time really
counts for short films so if your film
is like a seven minute short film but
two minutes of that are credits no no no
no fast fast fast for those credits you
know shove them up on the screen
sometimes people kickstarter
or one of those kind of things and they
promise credits on the screen
make them almost unreadable
and have them go there if you're putting
your film online you can have long
credits at the end because nobody's
sticking around for that either as soon
as they see the film is over they just
stop watching it nobody in features
nobody wants to see credits nobody wants
to see credits but don't have long
credits on your film and have that be
part of your running time that hamper
you for uh you know because again
running time counts
sure i mean theoretically you could
always have a website that has that
mentions the backers but i realize it's
not the same as as being in the credits
but and you know there isn't necessarily
one version of your film maybe you have
the festival version of your film that
doesn't have those long credits in it
and then you have the web version that
does have all those long credits in it
so you know there are ways to deal with
it in that way too
how many different story structures are
there for short films
short films can be anything so there
could be as many different story
structures as you want it to be
but i don't think there's like an a plot
and a b plot and a c plot like you would
have in like a tv show or something like
that you really just want to have the a
plot
you know there might be a little teeny
bit of a runner but doubtful in that way
um and you know that's the thing about
short films it's not the same you know
we don't have like there's gonna be a
gangster uh film so these are the rules
for a gangster film um there is this is
my personal opinion um some people might
feel that there should be more structure
in that way but i say anything goes
whatever you want to do do
can a short film be a series of images
without a protagonist
and no structure
so what do you well how do you define
what a short film is and you know
there's um experimental shorts
that are very famous and are very um
interesting to watch but there's no
story line whatsoever it's just images
that are happening and that's fine again
know who's to define what a short film
is and if you say your film is
experimental and that's what you want to
do with it then go for it if that's what
your vision is um and you know sometimes
people love that because it's like okay
we're gonna program this one film that
is like a tarantino wannabe kind of film
and we're gonna program this one short
film that's like a horror film and then
we need to do something different we
can't do another horror film or another
coming of age so let's put in the weird
you know
artsy thing that just delights us you
know there's also like dance films where
people just film a dance performance or
music videos there's a lot of music
videos that people consider a short film
or you know who's to safe is it just a
music video or is it cinematic enough to
make who decides these things there's
again there's no short film board that
says you are a short you are music video
you are a commercial you are just track
i have no idea what you are
you as the filmmaker get to find what it
is so if you're not a narrative
storyteller and you just want to make
these beautiful things then that's
fabulous now that's not the person
that's going to be hired to direct the
next star wars film you know and so if
that's your goal you should make
something that makes you more obviously
the
person who's going to direct the next
star wars film um but
you that maybe that shows you have such
a unique artistic point of view and
people think
this person might be really interesting
to make a different kind of
spider-man film or something like that
they have such a unique um eye and
thinking and you know
if that's who you are then
be who you are in your short film work
short film format just do it
so something that doesn't really have
much of a story line that might be more
geared toward let's say contemporary art
museum there are museum pieces but i
have also we've seen museum pieces play
in film festivals so um yeah an example
of a museum piece the museum decides you
know is this something that is worthy of
being in our halls now they also may be
completely wrong too and they're like it
just seems like a bunch of drips on
canvas who's this jackson pollock after
all you know who's to say who's right or
wrong and because short filmmakers um
you know on the front lines of doing
something unique and different people
might not understand their film right
away and then in five years time you
look back and you're like oh you know
look at this crazy thing christopher
nolan was doing five years ago i saw a
short film that just did that exactly
you know we sometimes are too ahead of
the curve and are doing really special
and unique stuff that is not what people
are used to and that's great too we
don't want to see the same old same old
we want to see something really
different and unique
right just to go back and watch cindy
sherman like old old videos online
yeah and it's like wow this is
this was ahead of its time yeah so cool
isn't that sunny and so like in short
films too they don't really age that
much really terrific short films
i mock like the lauren hardy short films
the one realers but people still go back
and look at those and love those and
think they're fabulous if you go back
and watch the oscar winners for
animation
from years ago whoa these things are
amazing and still seem really special
and unique nowadays
and same thing for live action there are
some live action short films that just
blow you it's also really fun to go back
and see like the short films of
filmmakers like christopher nolan or
whatever and go back and see his short
film and you say oh
so george lucas when he was at usc did a
lot of short films
and some of them are incredibly boring
but still you see what that what he was
interested in and there was all these
sound things you could tell he was very
interested in sound and um and we can
see them now because usc owns those
films and shows those films but so it's
super interesting to see famous
filmmakers now what they were doing in
short films and you can see
you know i see their voice in it and
that's
those are special filmmakers obviously
um but yeah that's why it's really
worthwhile going back and seeing their
short films
you